hello freak [ __ ] and it what is Ann
Coulter do mean she want three help
books we can control she's a troll she
told her oh no and we're talking to be a
liberal like probably actually just one
of those she's just worried she's a
performance I got into performance yeah
exactly exactly a performance artist and
not a very good one because if she was
that that in Trump we trust book like
the whole cover like what in the [ __ ] is
that I mean it was just bizarre bizarre
that that like that she wrote that book
it was almost like okay this is cheap
even for her like this is just like a
cheap ploy during this whole Trump
movement she sees the the whole momentum
of the country its she's going to write
a book and put Trump in the title of
it's like so stupid but it's weird it's
just weird that it's so easy but it
makes sense just like we were talking
about how Reagan's sort of mobilized the
right-wing conservative people that were
Christians that really weren't about
politics before that and he kind of
brought them in people real like they
look at it and go hey look this is an
angle you know there's an angle we can
take that no one's been taking and this
you're right it felt like a bait and
switch this whole milla milla Berkeley
thing because they know exactly what's
going to happen when they go there and
of course that's exactly what happens
and then they can use it to be like free
free speech I mean it's just so he knows
what he's doing
yeah model is a clever guy he's very
clever I mean he knows exactly is doing
and you know and Milo at one point in
time by the way was a guy who was very
anti hate speech you know and it was
very anti shutting down people who are
writing things to her people people like
pulled quotes of his from the past which
is interesting because I mean I'm sure
people's philosophies changed I'm sure
mine have yours have but this is like
one more piece of evidence that what
you're seeing with a lot of people that
are in the public eye that are involved
in this whole political arena is you're
seeing there working angles like what's
the angle like okay let's go that way
and you can justify it look I could
justify a lot of different angles if I
want to do that if I wanted to be if I
wanted to be in an anti-trump protesters
anti-free speech poster if I wanted to
be a person who thinks that free speech
should be limited because you hate
speech is not
protected by the Constitution like
Howard Dean just said that [ __ ]
[ __ ]
he said hate speech is not protected by
the Constitution never dick Mallard yeah
yes it is Howard you [ __ ] idiot
you're goddamn representative why I see
parties exist actually and they can have
rallies you know like that yeah that's
that happened I forget we was saying it
about two but it was ridiculous our he
would the way he said it it wasn't even
like justified it wasn't like someone
was saying okay we need to gather up
these gay people and hang him from stops
on that's not what people are saying it
was wasn't anything that extreme where
he oh I think it was Ann Coulter I think
the coroner for who pull that up see if
you can find it I'm pretty sure Howard
Dean was talking about Ann Coulter and
he was saying that hate speech is not
protected by the First Amendment so what
are you advocating around you know to
round up a Nicole Hill or a surfer he's
just saying that she should be that you
can stop her talk he just you know what
it was are not poorly thought out
statement that got trampled right you
know and just thrown out and everybody
is sort of repeating it over and over
and over again and I just don't think he
thought about it when you saying it I
think about a lot yeah here it is was it
about Ann Coulter yes what about her
cultures upcoming speech in Vermont
the Vermont DNC chair Howard Dean
elaborated on this argument that Ann
Coulter's upcoming speech at Berkeley
does not have to occur because hate
speech in quotes is not protected by the
First Amendment
[ __ ] you man
you
[Applause]
[Music]